persiste la crisis de combustible en
Cuba las extensas filas de automóviles
en las cercanías de las estaciones de
gasolina son el indicador de la falta
del carburante según las autoridades por
el momento la situación permanecerá
igual o sea mantenido reducido las
cifras que hoy podemos distribuir Para
qué para no tener una un
desabastecimiento total de combustible
en el país Venezuela histórico
abastecedor de crudo a la isla ha bajado
considerablemente los envíos a Cuba un
vacío que la Habana ha intentado suplir
con envíos de Rusia y México sin embargo
esa vía tampoco ofrece pronta solución
ellos han tenido problemas también con
los insumos para producir y han tenido
problemas para poder cumplir con con
nosotros los los compromisos En medio de
una inflación sin precedentes la falta
del diesel genera un alza adicional de
los precios uno
de lo que costaba anteriormente Y cuando
uno le pregunta dice es que es
combustible es que no hay gasolina es
que Y entonces es muy difícil es muy
difícil también que hay pocos hay pocos
carros también pero un anuncio en
particular marcó la gravedad de la
escasez la dirección del país suspendió
las acostumbradas marchas por el día de
los trabajadores y se decidió por una
celebración más austera manteniendo su
conmemoración pero en condiciones de
racionalidad y máxima autoridad este
trance se desarrolla pocos días de que
el gobierno cubano encabezado por Miguel
díaz-canel tomara posesión en un segundo
mandato la falta de un plan económico
efectivo por parte del gobierno la
crisis económica mundial así como las
sanciones impuestas por Estados Unidos
han hecho que la isla experimente una de
las crisis económicas más fuertes de su
historia reciente